bonjour un mauvais tie brothers merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte france
alors le président a évoqué une dette de
la france à l'égard de la polynésie
c'est ce que vous attendiez non pas du
tout ce qu'on savait l'évocation de
cette dette a déjà été fait à l'époque
par le président chirac donc là rien de
nouveau sous le soleil
en revanche ce que nous attendions ce
que les polynésiens attendait c'est
cette demande de pardon qui visiblement
on n'est toujours pas à l'ordre du jour
justement j'avais je vais vous le dire
pas d'excusés de la part d'ea d'emmanuel
macron au nom de la france
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
ressentez justement après cette non
excuses je le ressens beaucoup de
déception et j'ai quand même le
sentiment que ces quatre jours passés
par emmanuel macron polisy viser plus à
lancer sa campagne des présidentielles
qu'à réellement venir rencontrer l'âme
des polynésiens quand bien même les mots
utilisés et et lyrique théâtraux le
contenu et au final est assez creux le
président a également dit vouloir la
vérité la transparence sur surtout ses
essais nucléaires à des archives vont
être ouvertes
qu'est ce que vous attendez justement de
l'ouverture de ses archives écoutez les
archives
encore faut-il savoir de quelles
archives repart déjà les archives on va
dire les petits contiendrait le plus
d'informations utiles ne sont pas
ouvertes c'est ce que c'est ce qui est
classé comme archive seront différentes
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une archives
proliférante par exemple c'est
l'emplacement des puits de tir d essai
souterrain et bien comme nous n'aurons
jamais accès à ces archives là nous ne
serons jamais quel est le degré de
radioactivité à l'endroit de ses puits
de tir aujourd'hui qu'elle est comment
vous vivez ça vous justement en
polynésie
française cette visite du président
justement et le fait qu'il ne s'excuse
toujours pas au nom de la france
nous nous trouvons cette visite un peu
déplacé à l'heure où la fin c'est
l'hexagone est confronté à de réels
problèmes de graves problèmes je crains
que le plaisir en marquant son arrivée à
paris puisqu'il est parti hier soir de
poésie au delà du choc thermique soit
confronté à d' autres shops est ce que
vous avez pu vous rencontrer le
président emmanuel macron ou où
certaines de vos de vos connaissances et
est-ce que vous lui avez parlé justement
de deux de ses excuses que les
polynésiens attendent
vous savez nous avons exprimé le souhait
que une réunion puisse se tenir ici avec
tous ceux qui ont refusé de participer à
la table ronde qui a été organisée à
paris ce choix n'a pas été entendue donc
le plaisir d'un cran n'a pas souhaité
rencontrer on va dire d'autres voies que
celles qui ont chanté ses louanges
le président s'est ainsi engagé à la
dépollution des sites encore atteint par
l'armée est ce que ces zones sont
justement nombreuses en polynésie alors
les zones polluées sont nombreuses mais
attention à ce qui a été dit le
président on ne sait absolument pas
engagé à dépolluer il s'est simplement
engagé à retirer les équipements qui ont
été laissés sur place
c'est à vrai dire assez insidieux
puisque il s'agit en fait pour l'état
d'effacer les traces de ces essais
nucléaires et non pas de réellement
dépolluer ce sont des vieux hangar ce
sont des bunkers
ce sont des des engins qui vont être
enlevés mais la pollution réelle elle
est au fond de ces 2 quid qui font plus
d'un kilomètre de profondeur à mon
endroit
la pollution réelle elle est au fond du
lagon ou droits sur le banc de colette
du plutonium est encore le déposer merci
beaucoup mon état et brothers sommes
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui sur
arte france rappelle que vous êtes
député gauche démocrate et républicaine
de polynésie française merci à vous